well I agree with mr. cops actually he
knows far more about the the sort of
secret working to the FCC than most of
us will could ever possibly know it is
true it is not traditional for the FCC
to circulate its orders ahead of a vote
and that one reason is that they may
still making change to them so well I'd
like to see the full 332 pages that are
allegedly in this report in order I
understand that we do have to to wait
until the vote but but given the sort of
magnitude of what's happening and given
just the size literally of what's coming
you can understand why members of
Congress and others are you know
increasingly agitated about what's
coming Michael cops is the interest over
this issue something you think we're
going to see in the future now that
technology and the internet is such an
important factor in the world of
business and impersonal lives as well in
the ways it's never been before I really
think so isn't it amazing that we've had
over four million people contact the FCC
for something as seemingly arcane as net
neutrality which i think is not a very
organizing kind of terminology and then
going even beyond that to title to but
that's because people really understand
that what we're talking about is their
communications infrastructure their
platform to talk to one another to find
jobs to keep job to do jobs educate
themselves take care of their health
it's integral to their lives it's huge
just as the infrastructure of the 21st
century so of course they have an
interest in and that interest is going
to grow and I think as media gives it
more and more attention like you've done
through the years and other media is
starting to do people going to going to
be even more involved than they have
been before and I think that's good
that's democracy that's the way policy
should meet my head Larry Downes we also
need more interest from Congress as a
result well I think so I mean you know
Congress even a year ago undertook this
very committee a starting point of
looking at the communications act as a
whole it hasn't been you know
significantly updated since 1996 and
that's a process that could take years
to do but obviously we need as the
Commissioner Copps says we need 21st
century regulation and and and that's up
to Congress to do